what digits could replace the question
mark in the hundreds place to make this
statement true
four thousand
question mark hundreds twenty-nine
rounds to five thousand if we round to
the nearest thousand
so we want a number whose nearest
thousand is five thousand it's closer to
five thousand than any other thousand
and what we know about our number so far
is it starts with four thousand
then we'll fill in the digit for the
hundreds
and ends with 29. so we want to know
what digits from zero to nine can we
fill in here
so that this number is closer to 5000
than any other thousand
well the only other thousand this could
be close to is four thousand
because we're starting with a four here
all of our numbers will be between four
thousand and five thousand so let's draw
that let's show that on a number line
here's a number line that goes from
four thousand to five thousand and then
the hundreds here are marked so this
would be four thousand one hundred four
thousand two hundred four thousand three
hundred four thousand four hundred
so on all the way to four thousand nine
hundred and then finally five thousand
so if we wanna fill in digits here
then we can graph them on our number
line and see
what are they nearest to are they
nearest to 5 000 or are they nearest to
4 000.
just to look at an example
if we plot a number right here
whatever number this point represents
what is its nearest thousand
well it is literally nearest
to five thousand
so it would round to five thousand that
would be its nearest thousand
but if for example we had a point that
was say somewhere like this
this points nearest thousand would be
four thousand this point would round
down to four thousand because we can
look and see it is closer to four
thousand than it is to five thousand it
is nearer
so let's look back now at our number and
try to fill in some digits and see where
they land on this number line
let's fill in the first possible digit
we could fill in here as a zero
so this would be four thousand zero
hundreds twenty nine
well that would be between four thousand
and four thousand one hundred it's
greater than four thousand but not quite
all the way to four thousand one
so we could plot that probably somewhere
just estimating a little bit about right
here a little closer to 4000 than 4100
and now looking at this number
we can see it is much closer to four
thousand its nearest thousand is
definitely four thousand it takes far
longer to get to five thousand
so
zero will not work
so we can take away
it's not going to be a
and i don't know that we need to try all
10 numbers what we can do is look down
here let's look at this graph and see
which section of it which section of
this number line is closer to 5 000
and the answer would be if we find right
in the middle here four thousand five
hundred
anything greater than this will round up
to five thousand
from the halfway point up
we'll round up to five thousand
so what points knowing
that this right here
is four thousand
five hundred
what numbers or what digits could we
fill in here to get a number that's
greater than four thousand five hundred
because anything less than that's gonna
round down be closer to four thousand
and so
we could try four thousand let's just
put a five in
would be right after 4500 somewhere
about like this
that is closer just barely but it's
closer to 5000 so 5 works 5 is a digit
that we could
use what about four
if we fill in a four here
we have four thousand four hundred
well that's going to be just to the left
of four thousand five hundred this line
is four thousand four hundred here's
four thousand five hundred
so that point will come somewhere around
here
which just barely rounds down to four
thousand it's close to the middle but a
little bit closer a little bit nearer to
four thousand its nearest thousand is
four thousand
so four will not work
five does work and from here i think we
can figure out our solution almost
without even using the number line if
4400 was too small well then 4 300 is
definitely too small and 200 and 100 and
we already saw zero hundreds was way
here way down here which is way too
small
and then we know five thousand four
thousand five hundred twenty-nine works
that's big enough so anything bigger
will only get closer to five thousand
anything bigger than five in the
hundreds place
will only move us closer farther to the
right
so any digit five or greater would work
here would round up to five thousand
so the digits that are five or greater
are five
and then six
seven
eight
and nine
those are the possible digits that we
could fill into our hundreds place so
that our number rounds to 5 000 as its
nearest thousand the solutions are 5 6 7
8 and 9.